foreign
subject in JavaScript after merge
anticipation the react team has finally
released react version 18.0 which
includes the highly anticipated
concurrent rendering features hello
everyone and welcome back to another
video by simply learned this is anubhub
and in this video we are going to talk
about react 18 and its new features but
before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and
press the Bell icon so you will never
miss any update from Simply learn so
without further Ado let's begin first
let me tell you what react.js is so what
is react.js react is a JavaScript
library used to build fast and
interactive mobile and web applications
it is an open source reusable component
based front-end library of JavaScript
react is a combination of HTML and
JavaScript it provides a re-burst and
opiniated way to build modern
applications so let's move ahead and I'm
going to ask you one question okay
so let's see
how many ways are there to Define
variables in es6 which is ecmascript
so
pause this video right now and answer
this question in the comment section
below so the answer of this question is
three
so the three variables defined in
ecmascript 6 is where lit and constant
moving ahead
now we'll see the new feature that are
introduced in react 18.
the first one is concurrent features
then we have transitions
and after that the mean is suspense on
the server
moving ahead now we'll see the
improvements that are done in react 18.
automatic batching
better rendering and then performance
so some things have changed like before
we used to write react Dom dot render
wait let me explain it for you
after we installed react 18 go to the
index.js file there change the react Dom
dot render now we'll write react Dom dot
create root to create a root and then
render our app using root let's discuss
about reactating
so react was released in March 2022 and
you can install it with the help of npm
and yarn
let's move ahead and see what's new in
react 18.
so there are features like automatic
batching transitions suspense on the
server and concurrent react
now we'll start with the automatic
batching
so in automatic batching All State
modifications made using event handlers
are grouped together using react
buildings batching functionalities so it
prevents the files from going through a
pointless rendering procedure react 18
also features a modified version of
batching called react 18 automatic
batching that group All State
modifications made by create route
together so automatic batching is
nothing but to do all the micro tasks
together at the end of the task to save
time let me show you an example of
automatic batching
earlier the program used to render in
each step but now with automatic
rendering this will only render at the
end of the task
so as you can see in this program
this set is fetching false set error
null set form status successful okay so
earlier first render will be performed
in this part set is fetching the second
render is performing when it is calling
set error and the third render is
performing when it is calling set form
status okay but now it will just read
satisfetching set error and in the last
it will render at only one time okay so
this was automatic batching
let's move ahead on transition
so a transition is a New Concept in
Riyadh to description between
urgent and non-urgent updates in Urgent
updates it will reflect direct
interactions like typing clicking
pressing Etc the transition updates the
transition of the UI from one view to
another so let me give you an example if
you are doing a task and another urgent
task comes in that has a higher priority
so react will stop that task and work on
the higher priority task
and then start the task again
so the transition is done like this okay
if you are doing one task and some other
urgent task comes up it will stop the
earlier task and start on the higher
priority task
now let's move ahead with this suspense
on the server
before react 18 was introduced if one
component of an app is slow it slows
down the entire app yes but with react
18 if one component is low it will not
slow down the entire app now suspense
allow you to instruct react to send HTML
for other components such as loading
spinner before sending HTML from the
placeholder So This Server renderer will
then insert its HTML into the same
stream once the slow component is
prepared and has fetched its data react
suspense is a feature that enables
developer to monitor the rendering
element while the process is still in
process
it then displays its fallback
functionality
this functionality can be used in
conjunction with the transition API with
the most recent react version it even
pauses the rendering schedule to lessen
the effect of loading by preventing the
content from being changed
okay the render sequence is quite
helpful since it provides a calm loading
State while the user is still dealing
with a network conflict
okay this is a very good functionality
that has introduced with us since react
18 comes with a sequence it allows us to
designate fallbacks for UI element that
are yet to be seen on the screen
therefore using the sequence tag we
could wrap a single slow component And
Delay the component loading also you can
configure a fallback to show a loading
animation so this is how we used to
write the code
but now with the help of sequence we are
using the code like this
okay let's move ahead and talk about
concurrency in react
now react can interrupt pause restart or
quit a render in react 18 with
concurrent rendering this enables react
to react rapidly to user inputs while
engaging in the time consuming rendering
operations we will also talk about the
examples of concurrent rendering later
but let me first tell you react 18
introduced the foundation of concurrent
rendering and new features such as
sequence stream servering streaming
server rendering and transition are
powered by concurrent rendering as a
react developer you concentrate on how
you want the user experience to be
delivered and react take care of the
technical details now let me give you an
example
concurrent react can remove UI elements
from the screen and add them later while
restoring the previous state
react should be able to restore the
previous screen in the same state it was
before for instance when a user tabs
away from one screen and comes back to
it we intend to provide a new component
name off screen in a future Miner that
follows this pattern off screen can also
be used to create new user interface
element in the background so that they
are ready before the user reveals them
now we'll talk about a new hooks so the
new hooks are introduced in react 18 let
me talk about them
so the first is use ID
use transition use deferred value
using external store
and use insertion effect
you can use all these hooks now we'll
talk about the strict mode
now this trick mode is more stricter
okay when using react 18 strict mode
components will be mounted unmounted and
then remounted with a previous state by
remounting trees using the same
component State before unmounting react
will be able to instantly mount a
previous screen in the future
thanks to the reusable State now we'll
see the changes done on the client
server and library site
okay let's start
change is done on react 18.
one is client side
server side
and the library side now we'll talk
about the client side changes in client
side render is now being created as
create root as you can see in this image
we are first using
if you'll open the index.js file in your
react you'll see this file okay in here
you will see if you were using react Dom
dot render but now it's like root dot
render
okay like create root here importing the
create route now the const root equals
to create root now we can use the root
because we also gave the constant root
equals to create root
now moving ahead on the second one which
is unmounted component at node is now
become root dot unmount okay so before
we were using this function but now it's
like root dot unmount then we'll call in
the element
now now we'll talk about
react.dom.hydrate which is now converted
into hydrate dot root
call hydrate in react 17 and Below to
attach react to its extinct HTML that
was already rendered by react in a
server environment
using this react 18 will warn that your
app will behave as it fits running on
react 17.
now we'll talk about the server-side
changes
on server side render to pipe stream is
now on the Node environment and render
to readable stream is on the edge
environment and render to string is now
deprecated
now we'll talk about library site
changes
there are new features like use ID using
external store use insertion effect so
finally I would like to tell you guys
that the react focuses on improving the
user interface and is constantly working
on it so with this we have read the end
of this video on reactating new features
and updates
for more videos like this please
subscribe to Simply learn thanks for
watching until next time stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here